the dry streak continues here in
southern nevada although we will be
cloud free for
today we won't be smoke free we will
show you that there are no alerts for
today but we're
taking a close look at those smoky
conditions for today
back again showing you those
temperatures above normal 98 degrees for
today's high
are normal conditions of 95 degrees we
will be one degree warmer than we were
yesterday
record number 109 said back in 1948
and those lows close to those normal
conditions 76 degrees satellite radar
we're still tracking that ridge of high
pressure
it's our dominating feature but right
behind it
by midweek we're going to be talking
more about a low pressure system looking
to kick in from the pacific
northwest your futurecast will show you
very dry
conditions for the next several days
really no sign of
any rain but that low pressure system
will bring
more winds by midweek you're going to
notice conditions remaining light and
variable for today
for tomorrow we can expect some breezes
mainly in the afternoon
and in terms of the temperatures that
low pressure system will eventually
bring us cooler conditions
not a huge jump from last week from that
20 to 30 difference
but more like five degrees cooler by the
end of the week
today though enjoy from that sunshine 87
degrees around that 10 a.m start east
winsting six miles per hour
96 degrees around 2 p.m and you can see
around 6 p.m
we're still following those upper 90s
with east winds staying
very tranquil the next few days
temperatures remaining pretty much the
same 90 degrees by monday
99 on tuesday before we increase back
again to the triple digits
on wednesday for the mountains today 76
degrees lots of sunshine east winds
staying
5 to 15 miles per hour red rock you'll
be in the 90s for
today it looks like a picture-perfect
weekend except for those smoky skies
highs for today in the lakes 98 degrees
north winds staying 5 to 10 miles per
hour before they shift
to the west laughlin with a high of 103
out there for today
tonight's low 75 degrees clear skies
east southeast winds staying tranquil
even calmer around that midnight hour
here's your sally j
seven day forecast in case you missed it
above normal temperatures we're starting
with 98 degrees for today we continue
that number
and then eventually the triple digits
return back again for wednesday into
thursday
we're expecting some breezy conditions
all week long
a little bit more windier on friday as
we expect that low pressure system to
give those cooler conditions for
saturday
96 degrees and those lows in the mid 70s
have a beautiful day